this is wrong before disturbing his  sacred solitude we shouldn't have come  this scene is henry david thoreau  naturalist and writer being a real jerk  to guests George and Emily these are not  my guests because I didn't even invite  them he's a little bit of a letdown but  in a funny way I'd rather sit on a  pumpkin and have it all to myself then  be crowded on a velvet cushion write  that down  he's a naturalist she assumes they'll be  a good man he's not how do I care about  your tree you said you loved the woods I  love my woods everyone really makes it  big during their lifetime they become  insufferable Emily Dickinson didn't get  to become big in her lifetime Henry  David Thoreau did and he was  insufferable you're a ditch never meet  your heroes  [Music]  you